ABBOTT'S CLAIMS WILL BE LOOKED
INTO AND INVESTIGATIONED.
>>> THIS WEEK WE'VE BEEN SHOWING
YOU THE ROOTS OF THE BORDER
CRISIS, WHY PEOPLE MAKE THE
DANGEROUS JOURNEY TO THE U.S. IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
MANUEL BOJORQUEZ REPORTS FROM
GUATEMALA ON HOW CLIMATE CHANGE
IS FORCING MANY INTO A DIFFICULT
CHOICE.
>> Reporter: IT'S WRITTEN IN THE
HILLSIDES AS FAR AS RUBEN CHAY
IS CONCERNED.
THE CROPS THAT HAVE SUPPORTED
GENERATIONS OF HIS FAMILY IN THE
HIGHLANDS ARE GONE.
THEY'VE NEVER SEEN IT LIKE THIS
BEFORE.
SO THIS WOULD BE FULL OF LEAVES.
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE ]
AD INSTEAD IT'S DRY.
THIS IS THE COFFEE BEAN.
NO GOOD.
THE COFFEE AND CARDEMOM STOOD NO
CHANCE.
THIS VALLEY TURNED INTO A LAKE
AFTER BACK-TO-BACK HURRICANES
SLASHED THE REGION LAST YEAR
WITH INTENSITY AND RAINFALL
BELIEVED TO BE MAGNIFIED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE.
LIKE MANY HERE, LURED BY
BILLBOARDS ADVERTISING A
FARMER'S DREAM, HE TOOK OUT A
LOAN TO GET THE OPERATION
RUNNING AGAIN, BUT NOTHING'S
GROWN.
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE ]
YOU HAVE A DEBT, YOU HAVE NO WAY
OF REPAYING IT.
YOUR CROPS ARE RUINED.
THE SIGN DRAWING HIS ATTENTION
NOW IS A SMUGGLER'S, ADVERTISING
A TRIP TO THE U.S.
>> CLIMATE CHANGE IS COMING ON
TOP OF PREVIOUS PROBLEMS LIKE
POVERTY, FOOD INSECURITY --
>> Reporter: EDWIN CASTELLANOS
STUDIES CLIMATE CHANGE AT THE
GOVERNMENT OF GUATEMALA.
>> THE PROBLEM IS NOT ONLY WE
ARE SEEING EXTREME EVENTS IN
TERMS OF TOO MUCH RAIN, WE ARE
ALSO SEEING THE OPPOSITE IN
TERMS OF TOO LITTLE RAIN.
>> Reporter: PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY ARE EXPERIENCING SEVERE
DROUGHT.
>> WE'VE SEEN A HUGE INCREASE IN
EXTREME EVENTS INCLUDING
FLOODING STORMS, BUT ALSO
DROUGHT.
>> Reporter: HE POINTED US TO
HIS RESEARCH SHOWING A DRAMATIC
SPIKE IN SEVERE WEATHER EVENTS
HERE OVER THE LAST DECADE
COMPARED TO THOSE PAST.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S ALWAYS A BIG
DEBATE AROUND CLIMATE CHANGE.
SOME PEOPLE DON'T BELIEVE IN IT.
YOU SAY CLIMATE CHANGE IS A
FACTOR THAT IS DRIVING PEOPLE TO
THE UNITED STATES?
>> UH-HUH.
YES.
I THINK THAT IF YOU ASK MOST
PEOPLE HERE IN GUATEMALA, IT
WOULD BE THAT MOST PEOPLE
BELIEVE IN CLIMATE CHANGE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE SEEN THE
CHANGE IN THE CLIMATE.
>> Reporter:HAT CAN BE DONE TO
KEEP PEOPLE HERE?
>> BASICALLY, THESE ARE FAMILIES
WHO HAVE LIVED IN EXTREME
POVERTY FOR MANY YEARS.
AND SO THEY ARE NOT REALLY
EXPECTING BIG CHANGES.
IT'S MORE CHANGE, IF MORE
AMOUNTS OF HELP WILL MAKE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE FOR THESE FAMILIES.
>> Reporter: REBUBIN DOESN'T WA
TO LEAVE HIS WIFE AND 5-YEAR-OLD
SON, BUT STRUGGLES TO ENSHVISIOA
FUTURE ON THE ONLY HILLSIDES
HE'S EVER KNOWN.
>> SO MANY PEOPLE THERE MAKING A
DECISION OUT OF PURE
DESPERATION.
>> I NEVER MADE A CONNECTION,
THOUGH, UNT